Well,
the a book's subtitle
is the case or reasons,
science,
humanism and progress at all.
I'll begin with the,
with the progress because that was the
epiphany that more than anything inspired
the book.
I'd written a previous book,
the better angels of our nature when I
was surprised to come across data sets
showing that many measures of violence
it declined over the course of history.
I was stunned to see a graph that showed
the rates of homicide from England and
other western European countries from
the 13 hundreds to the 20th century
showing a decline of anywhere
from 35 to 50 in the chances of a,
of getting murdered.
Uh,
when I,
uh,
called attention to this
fact and a blog post,
I didn't got correspondence from
historians from international relations
scholars,
from sociologists say,
you know,
you could have mentioned other declines,
another decline of violence.
And one worst scholar showed me that
the rate of death and war had plummeted.
Another showed me that rates of domestic
violence have gone down still another
that rates of child abuse had gone down.
And I realized that the time that there
was an important story here that was,
uh,
that it had to be told that these
different declines of violence ought to be
presented to the world in
between a single pair of covers.
Uh,
just because it did seem to
be something of a pattern.
And as a psychologist it opened up
the challenge of how to explain it.
First of all,
how to explain the,
uh,
the fact that there's been,
that there is so much
violence in human affairs,
but also the fact that
it can be brought down.
Well,
I had a similar set of epiphany's that
led to the writing of enlightenment.
Now when,
uh,
after better angels was published,
um,
I started a couple of cross data showing
that other aspects of human wellbeing
had improved.
The rate of extreme poverty had plummeted
by but 50% just in three decades and
now stands less than 10%.
Life expectancy has been
increasing all over the world,
including the,
the poorest parts of the world.
Uh,
the,
the number of kids going
to school has increased.
We,
including girls,
more than 90% of people under the age
of 25 on the planet are illiterate.
Now we have more leisure time.
We're safer,
uh,
in measure after measure
life has been getting better.
And it's not the kind of development
that you could learn about reading the
papers.
Quite the contrary because
journalism covers what goes wrong.
Uh,
not what goes right.
You could easily come away with the
impression that the world is getting worse
and worse as a kind of
statistical illusion,
uh,
feeding a cognitive bias and not
realize until you looked at datasets,
how many ways in which life has improved,
including measures like war and crime,
uh,
which would,
what my guests are going in the wrong
direction as opposed to the right
direction.
That combined that the other motivation
for the book was a set of attacks on the
application of science to the
traditional domains of the humanities to,
to history,
to the arts,
to morality,
to language.
Uh,
a,
an effort that I think is quite
a celebrates the fact that,
that,
that scientific insights are
being brought to bear on,
um,
on Cuban affairs.
And how could they not give him that,
uh,
art in society or are in
a sense products of our,
our psychology products of human nature.
But,
uh,
in a lot of the intellectual life,
there's bitter resentment to any
application of scientific ideas or the
scientific mindset to,
to human affairs.
This was first noted by CP snow in his
famous lectures and [inaudible] and the
early,
late fifties,
early 1960s.
Uh,
but the conflict is very much with us.
I wrote an essay called
science is not your enemy,
which were published
in the new Republican,
which went viral.
And that was the immediate,
a kickoff for the proposal that
ended up in the enlightenment.
Now,
uh,
I was involved in something
of a literary spat with,
uh,
with,
Leon Wieseltier and editor
at the new republic.
But I quickly realized that,
uh,
two guys having an argument is
not enough to pump out a book.
And so I had the centerpiece of the book
just be the documentation of the fact
that most people are unaware of
namely back in most measures,
life has gotten better over time.
Now,
as with the better angels of our nature,
I didn't want to just
present a bunch of graphs.
So I did present many graphs,
but I wanted to explain them.
And it seemed to me that if we,
if there was any overarching
explanation as to why life get better,
it's that people,
uh,
in the past thought that by
understanding how the world works,
including ourselves,
uh,
we could try to solve problems,
remember what works,
uh,
drop the,
drop the failures.
And as we accumulate our,
our cultural knowledge,
uh,
we can improve our wellbeing.
And I attribute that mindset to the light,
the idea that we can use knowledge
to improve human wellbeing.
Now that might sound almost too banal
and that tried to be worth defending.
And so I thought that those
ideals very much needed a defense.